[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias
muchas gracias gente muy interesante por
acá y bueno mi tema hoy en día todo el
mundo escucha hablar de transformación
digital de innovación vemos ese tema en
todos los periódicos en la tele en los
libros la gente habla de transformación
digital de innovación y todos
correlacionan la transformación digital
y la innovación con tecnología pero
realidad la transformación digital va
mucho más allá de la tecnología la
transformación digital conlleva un
cambio cultural
la transformación digital al llevar un
cambio cultural al conllevar un cambio
cultural exige que no sea un tema
solamente de un área de la empresa sino
que sea un tema de toda la empresa de
toda la organización todos tenemos que
estar comprometidos con la
transformación digital no un área
toda la cultura tiene que emanar y todos
tenemos que respirar innovación y
transformación digital el día a día sin
embargo nos consume no nos da tiempo
para pensar en innovación
trabajamos 8 o 10 horas y sin embargo
estamos pensando en innovar pero no
podemos innovar si no tenemos tiempo si
no le damos tiempo a la innovación y la
transformación digital y para lograr eso
tenemos que darle tiempo a empresas como
google le dice a los empleados tienes
10% de tu tiempo para innovar para
pensar en cosas diferentes que haya
sabido el google card haya salido
aplicaciones como gmail no entonces hay
que darle el tiempo pero más allá de
solamente dar el tiempo tenemos que
crear un entorno en la empresa en el
cual la empresa y la organización tiene
que estar dispuesta a asumir riesgos la
innovación la transformación digital no
es una certeza más bien todo lo
contrario cuando innovamos y hacemos
algo de transformación digital realmente
no sabemos cuál va a ser el resultado y
como organización tenemos
estar dispuestos a asumir ese riesgo y
esa incertidumbre
hay muchos obstáculos para la
transformación digital e innovación el
principal es que la gente y las empresas
y los los ejecutivos las empresas son
adversos al riesgo no les gusta tener
riesgo
cuando alguien viene con una idea
innovadora dicen lo que cuál va a ser el
retorno de inversión y esa no es la idea
si tú has innovar y vas a lograr una
transformación digital
tienes que estar dispuestos a asumir el
riesgo dispuestos a saber que esto puede
fallar la transformación digital a
diferencia de otras cosas en la empresa
no viene de abajo para arriba la
transformación digital de innovación
tiene que venir de arriba para abajo si
los niveles ejecutivos los directorios
de las empresas no están comprometidos
con una transformación digital la
transformación digital no va a suceder
esto no viene de abajo para arriba
estuviera de arriba para abajo
y otro tema muy importante que es un
obstáculo para transformación digital
son los caudillos y no estoy hablando de
gente de edad no tiene nada que ver con
edad hay caudillos que pueden ser muy
jóvenes muy mayores que pueden estar
pocos años muchos años en la empresa
pero si es esa gente que no quiere
cambiar y no quiere ir un paso más allá
lo primero que tenemos que hacer algunos
caudillos tenemos que ver de
convencerlos de traerlos a nuestro lado
para que puedan influenciar al resto
pero si no lo logramos lastimosamente
tenemos que hacerlos a un lado porque
van a ser un obstáculo para la
transformación digital e innovación
finalmente el otro obstáculo es el área
de recursos humanos hablamos de
innovación de transformación digital
pero seguimos contratando gente que no
es que tiene aversión al riesgo si hemos
cortado gente que no está preparada con
metodologías de innovación no si
queremos lograr una transformación
digital la empresa tenemos que
involucrarnos aclarar recursos humanos y
decirles a ellos que contraten gente que
esté dispuesta a tomar riesgos
la parte más difícil la transformación
digital es el cambio cultural pero
tienes un experto en este tema y dice en
esto la tecnología no es tan importante
como la cultura muchos pensamos que la
teología es toda una transformación
digital y no lo es la cultura es lo más
importante pero dónde está yendo porque
las industrias se están transformando
digitalmente porque todo el mundo y no
solamente en la banca sino en muchas
industrias hablan de transformación
digital hablan de transformación digital
porque el cliente hoy en día ya es
digital en todas las industrias en todas
las industrias en las industria minera
en industria agrícola industria de
ruidera la industria de la banca el
cliente ya es digital y qué significa
eso este es el nuevo paradigma del
cliente digital el cliente digital es
diferente a los demás clientes hoy en
día y esto no tiene que ver con un tema
de edad nuevamente hay clientes
digitales que pueden tener que pueden
ser muy mayores o muy menores no son
temas de edad es un tema de
comportamiento del cliente digital hoy
en día compara
hoy en día antes de subirte a comprar un
teléfono ya has entrado a google has
visto la marca de ese teléfono ya has
visto cuáles son las características y
qué dice la gente de ese teléfono antes
de siquiera acercarte a la tienda a
comprarlo igual si vas a comprar un auto
agarras y entras a google ves el tipo de
auto que vas a comprar ves qué dice la
gente de ese auto el cliente hoy en día
está informado y no podemos nosotros
negarnos de eso no podemos decir que el
cliente no está informado el cliente
está comparando constantemente y como el
cliente está comparando constantemente
nosotros tenemos que darle información a
ese cliente mientras más información le
demos ese cliente a través de
plataformas en la web en el celular en
las redes sociales a través de marketing
digital ese cliente va a estar más
informado y más informada
y en muchos casos tu producto puede ser
un poquito inferior al de la competencia
pero si tú le informan más al cliente es
el cliente te va a comprar a ti
tienes que darle el mayor tipo de
información al cliente tienes que
mantenerlo informado para que el cliente
te pueda comprar lo que ese cliente está
comprando pero también con la
transformación digital tenemos que
buscar comunicarnos constantemente con
el cliente tenemos que comunicarnos
digitalmente al cliente hoy en día no le
gusta que lo llamen por teléfono o no le
gusta llamar un call center es lo menos
lo menos que le gusta lo que más le
gusta ese cliente es comunicarse a
través de las plazas digitales donde ese
cliente vive y el cliente hoy en día
vive en facebook vive en whatsapp vive
en link team vive en youtube nos tenemos
que comunicar con sus clientes a través
de estas plataformas porque es ahí donde
vive el cliente el cliente no vive
agarrado al teléfono llamando al call
center el cliente vive en esas plazas
digitales y cuando nos comunicamos
digitalmente porque nuestros clientes
tenemos comunicarnos por estos medios
porque porque es ahí donde viven ellos y
ellas el país más grande del mundo cuál
es
no es china el país más grande del mundo
es facebook tiene 2.2 mil 200 millones
de habitantes nosotros vivimos en ese
país todos los días
y es ahí donde tenemos que nos hacemos
que ir a esa plaza digital donde está el
cliente y comunicarnos con el cliente en
esa plaza digital si queremos ser
digitales no tenemos que hacer que el
cliente venga a nosotros no también para
buscarla en la trasformación de irak
tenemos que hacer un montón de análisis
de datos tenemos que utilizar la edad de
nuestros clientes
tenemos que aprender qué es lo que ellos
y ellas están haciendo qué es lo que
quieren
y muchos nosotros no hacemos eso tenemos
un montón de data nuestros clientes
los bancos por ejemplo hoy en día saben
donde yo tengo mi café todas las mañanas
porque pago con esa tarjeta saben donde
yo compro pañales para mis hijos porque
yo pago con esta tarjeta no pero ellos
no hacen nada por llegarme a mí con esa
información si queremos una empresa
digital tenemos que utilizar la data y
analizar la edad de nuestros clientes
para qué
para cabalmente anticipar las
necesidades de los clientes si tú
anticipa las ideas de los clientes ahí
vas a pasar vas a ser exitoso y exitosa
o tu empresa va a ser exitosa y exitosa
tienes que anticipar la necesidad tienes
que adivinar que lo que el cliente
quiere cuando alguien creó al iphone se
anticipó a lo que íbamos a creer que nos
recibamos a querer una computadora en
vez de un teléfono y es lo que ahora
todos nosotros utilizamos utilizamos una
computadora en vez de un teléfono
correcto pues tenemos que anticiparnos a
la ansiedad de los clientes y la mejor
manera de hacerlo es a través del
análisis data y para eso tenemos que
también crear contenido digital
atractivo no hay que colocar páginas web
donde somos quiénes somos desde nuestro
directorio visión misión no la gente no
le interesa ver eso a la gente le
interesa ir a tu plaza digital para para
ver cosas interesantes tenemos que poner
contenido digital que sea interesante
que sea relevante y la información de
quiénes somos quién es nuestro director
la foto del presidente de la empresa eso
no importa a la gente le interesa berta
está importante que le interesa
y con la gente pesada está la gente para
ir a plaza digital entonces tiene que
crear contenido digital relevante pero
el cliente hoy en día es muy impaciente
ante si alguien os decía tienes que
esperar todos tres días para este
trámite uno decía bueno también nuestros
días no estamos no están turno pero hoy
en día alguien te dice eso y te dice es
como puede ser dos o tres días porque no
me lo pueden regar esta tarde el cliente
es totalmente impaciente hoy en día
todos somos impacientes
y porque somos impacientes tenemos que
utilizar tecnologías como la
robotización de procesos con vpn un
business process manager como cdm
herramientas digitales que no cuestan
mucho y que nos permiten conocer bien a
nuestros clientes y que nos permite
atenderlos de manera más rápida
alguien decía de que de aquí a 12 años
el 47% de los trabajos tal y como los
conocemos ahora ya no van a existir van
a ser robotizados tenemos que empezar a
robotizar ese es el tipo de trabajo
nosotros en nuestras empresas para
atender a nuestros clientes de manera
más eficiente el cliente no espera y
cuáles son algunos tips que les puedo
dar para lograr una transformación
digital el primero no hagan pirotecnia
digital no lancen cohetes escribiendo
que va a suceder no porque eso te puede
quemar
si vas a hacer algo digital tienes que
tener un plan tienes que tener un
roadmap digital y es el roadmap digital
tiene que tener tres aristas la primera
tienes que ver como hago lo que estoy
haciendo ahora de mejor manera de manera
más eficiente con robotización con un
crm con un bpm cómo puedo lograr
maximizar lo que estoy haciendo ahora en
el segundo renglón tu puedes empezar a
explorar nuevas ideas de negocio puedes
empezar a ver qué dice mi mercado de
esto y en el tercer renglón puedes
empezar a ver cómo voy a cambiar mi
modelo de negocio como de aquí a cinco
años mi modelo de negocios es totalmente
diferente
y es lo que tienes que ir pensando esto
esto no es secuencial no puedes ir
haciendo al mismo tiempo y es lo que
tenemos que hacer para lograr un roadmap
digital pero también cuando hablamos de
transformación digital
hablamos de que pedimos a la gente que
no ve que se transforme pero no lo
capacitamos no lo capacitamos no la
capacitamos tenemos que dar las
herramientas a esas personas para que
logren una transformación digital y las
herramientas son las metodologías
rápidas de innovación como el line
startup el canvas el scrum design
thinking el sombrero son metodologías
que le ayuda a la gente a la empresa a
poder innovar para poder transformarse
digitalmente en cualquier empresa para
cualquier cosa que vamos a hacer nos
capacitamos tomamos cursos tomamos
diplomados correcto pero cuando vaya nos
dice vamos a innovar nos dicen que tú
eres de sistemas va a innovar es la
típica pero no es así no nos han
capacitado no nos han preparado tenemos
que prepararnos con las metodologías
para poder innovar y para poder lograr
una transformación digital el otro tema
es que tenemos que crear y vivir en sí
temas digitales qué significa eso hoy en
día la gente vive en plazas digitales
qué significa eso por ejemplo facebook
es una plaza digital es una plaza
digital donde nosotros vivimos todos los
días los bancos por ejemplo tiene una
plaza digital en sus portales porque
porque todos los días vamos a sus
portales para que para entrar a la banca
electrónica correcto pero en su portal
es una plaza digital que otros visitamos
como si visitamos una casa no pero nadie
nos invitó un refresco un tc un tecito
un café no no lo hacen no simplemente
vamos a esa casa hacemos clic en la
banca electrónica nada más ellos ellos y
ellas no están aprovechando el tema del
ecosistema digital hay que crear un
ecosistema digital de crear una plaza
digital y si no puedes crear una plaza
digital ve a la plaza digital donde
viven los clientes que es facebook
linkedin youtube tú tienes que estar en
esas plazas digitales
tienes que también colaborará con las
startups las startups tienen mucha más
energía tiene mucha más iniciativa para
que vamos a crear algo si ya está creado
y una startup lo ha hecho porque no
colaboramos con los startups porque no
colaboramos con el startup que tienen
otras tecnologías porque tratar de
hacerlo nosotros si podemos colaborar
con un startup es ideal porque no
solamente colaboras con la solución sino
que de startups te nutren desde energía
de innovación y de transformación
digital y lo que el otro tema que
tenemos que hacer es que tenemos que
crear y fomentar la innovación interna
tenemos que buscar que toda la gente que
trabaja para nuestra empresa nos pase
ideas de innovación para que nosotros
podamos ir tomando nota de esas ideas
colocándolas en un embudo de innovación
ir ejecutando las ideas de innovación
si no haces la mejor innovación no viene
de afuera no viene de los consultores no
viene de los expertos viene la propia
gente que trabaja con los clientes día a
día
tenemos que también aprender a crear un
producto mínimo viable tenemos que
aprender a equivocarnos rápido y
equivocarnos barato si te equivocas caro
y largo te puede costar el trabajo si te
equivocas rápido y barato aprendes vas y
tirando y eso es el link startup tienes
que aprender a sacar un producto
rápidamente al mercado testearlo
aprender recoger la data y tirar y
nuevamente volverlo a lanzar es la mejor
manera es la mejor manera de crear un
producto o un servicio rápidamente
equivocarse rápido equivocarse barato
pero lo más importante la transformación
digital lo más importante es tienes que
enfocarte en el cliente el cliente es el
rey y la reina ellos son los únicos
que saben qué es lo que quieren y que lo
que tú les puedes ofrecer y ellos son
los que te van te lo van a comprar al
final del día tu producto puede ser lo
mejor del mundo pero si ellos y ellas no
te lo compran no tienes un producto no
tienes un servicio es importante una
transformación digital enfocarte en qué
es lo que quieren esos clientes tienes
que pensar tienes que ver las hipótesis
tienes que ver realmente qué es lo que
ellos quieren qué es lo que necesitan
cómo puedo satisfacer sus necesidades no
tanto pensar en lo que tú puedes
construir si no solamente tienes que
pensar en lo que si deberías construirlo
y si esos clientes lo van a consumir
no es lo mismo conocer el camino que
recorrer el camino podemos hablar de
transformación digital de innovación
podemos volvernos expertos en hablar de
esto pero no es hasta que damos ese paso
de innovar de transformar digitalmente
nuestras personas nuestra empresa no es
hasta que hacemos eso que empezamos
realmente a innovar ya transformarnos
digitalmente acuérdense no es lo mismo
conocer el camino que es recorrer el
camino vayamos por ver por el camino de
la innovación y la transformación
digital saquemos ese pie de la cama y
comencemos a dar esos nuevos pasos de
innovación y transformación digital
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]